foreign
there's nothing holding these lovers
back
[Music]
yeah Shawn Mendes and Camila Cabello
getting cozy at Taylor Swift's heires
tour stop in New Jersey my guy I love
that guy and love is certainly in the
air as the two sway together and share a
smooch during T Swift's lover
as I do obviously like I love him in uh
he's my boyfriend but I've always loved
him as just I just love him you know
this is just the latest sighting as the
pair appear to be rekindling their
romance I know we're really young so I
don't want to jump like insanely fast
but I think when you find your person
you feel and you know that you found
your person oh my God this is a real
thing yep totally real check out Sean
and Camila strolling the streets of New
York just last week but it's it's fun
the singers who dated for two years
before Calling it Quits in November 2021
were spotted locking lips at Coachella
last month it just feels like oh my God
like we're kissing now at the time a
sourceful ET they aren't officially back
together but are enjoying each other's
company and seeing where things go I
think we're both equally very mushy and
I think we're both extremely mushy
people I think we're both super
sensitive which is creates a lot of
sensitive sensitivity in our
relationship our source adds Sean and
Camila are both attracted to each other
and care about the other and the two are
having fun so while we wait for the news
they're officially back together
[Music]
he's the best and I think we're really
supportive of each other and you know
always want to see each other fans can
Swoon over this recent PDA moment
[Music]
thank you